so long et Canada good we're really
excited to have you thank you for taking
the time to talk to me usually I not
drag queens in studio with me but in
these very unusual times this is a great
way to get to talk to you so thank you
hey I'm here for you guys
you are our Canadian queen of the season
okay I love that I am serving you Amanda
Bynes she's the man Canadian lacrosse
player realness don't know exactly how
the lacrosse is played but I'm gonna win
it is it wrong for me to say she's a
lacrosse Chester I thought it was hockey
yeah tell me about the experience of
drag race I interview a lot of drag
queens and the one thing they always
tell me is that walking into that work
room you think you have it in the bag
you're like yeah my looks are the best I
got this I got this I'm gonna win that
crown has it been harder than you
imagined being on the show I walked into
the workroom kind of like um ready for
whatever happened but not like I didn't
really have a lot of expectations
because everyone did one thing that
every Queen says it's nothing like you
expect so I was like alright then I'm
going to walk in with like no
expectations see what happens
it's definitely exhausting I mean they
are very long days we are filming and
you know it's one thing after another
and even you know in the last four weeks
you've seen we've had you know a rap
challenge we're doing choreography we're
doing improv acting and we're creating
gowns and garments she's very smart
her lyrics showed that she's in one the
joke with us and like knows how to play
to us without playing to us
I like that she gets fashion she gets
period fashion she gets fashion period
you're constantly being challenged in a
different way each week creatively which
will definitely you know your brain
starts like you know you're doing a
little bit of this you know I can't do
any more but you're doing a little bit
of that the whole time yeah I guess I
never walked in look like this like I
don't I don't believe in Esther day
walking into a room being like I got
this like screw all you like I'm the
best like I don't think that attitude
really has gotten me anywhere in my life
so I kind of walk into an when to any
new situation like ready to let it kind
of happen to me and open to whatever it
might be and see what happens from there
who do you think right now in the
competition is your biggest competition
who is Jackie Parks watching with an
eagle eye I think my biggest competition
is Gigi and Krystal I think that
definitely did they're still wants to
watch or but I Nica came up out of
nowhere and then improv challenge and
really impressed me with her common jobs
she's you are also an Iranian Queen
who's representing Middle Eastern Queens
which is fantastic on the show what does
that meet you to kind of have that
presence on the show that really hasn't
been there much yeah you know um I
wasn't ever sure if I like really wanted
to go on a platform as big as RuPaul's
Drag Race but you know with things in
the world not just the United States but
really globally you know taking this
turn to you know a little turn inward
many countries are turning inward in
terms of how they view others from
outside of their country how they view
immigrants how they view people from the
Middle East and I really wanted to take
this opportunity to put like a face and
a name so like someone who is living in
the United States with a green card who
is you know of Middle Eastern heritage
whose mom had to struggle the entire
time living in North America
with you know racism in trying to get an
apartment and you know all of the things
that I think people face you know
there's there's kind of these like
really distinct moments in my you know
childhood that I remember and a lot of
them were really hard for people of
Middle Eastern heritage you know I think
of like the Gulf War and 9/11 and things
that really kind of made the perception
of anyone who is from Iran or any of the
neighboring countries as somehow the
enemy so I wanted to kind of put a face
to that person who some people may think
is an enemy and to show that I'm not an
enemy the person princess of drag has
arrived what have you learned about
yourself throughout this whole kind of
pressure cooker experience that is
reality TV I think the biggest thing
I've learned is that I approached drag
in a different way than most of my peers
I guess I didn't realize this because
I'm normally preparing for my shows and
whatever by myself or you know with the
people who are in the show with me so
I've never been around so many different
drag themes to approach drag from such a
different point of view um but I
realized that I approach drag in a
little bit more of a I like to think
through everything I'm gonna do before I
do it usually which um I feel many drag
things a little more visceral and just
kind of like throw whatever it is out
there so I've learned to kind of embrace
the visceral side of drag a little bit
but a little bit more like you know
flash-in-the-pan seat of your pants kind
of experience the dragon be and let let
loose a little I guess I've been a
little bit more maybe careful as the
word with how I've approached my drag so
um being there is definitely I learned
that about myself and it's given me the
opportunities to be a little bit a
little more free with my drug this
outfit is very representative of
because it's a little retro but has a
little bit of that modern twist miss
Bouvier you stay I want to know how is
Jackie Cox spending this isolation
period the amazing thing about this
quarantine is it is giving us all a
window into you know maybe what the
future of performance and drag could be
because there's so many amazing ways we
can connect with our fans virtually that
I don't know if we think about all the
time and it's one of the cool gifts of
this time is to figure out what are some
neat ways to create content to like
interact with your fans in a way that
feels genuine but also feels like you
can actually connect with them I'm
definitely grateful for the opportunity
and privilege to be able to perform as
something as cool and as big as digital
drag Fest I'm also using it as an
opportunity to give back a little bit so
during the show there's the ability for
the audience to tip and you know it's
amazing enough that they're buying
tickets to the show so in terms of the
tips I'm donating half of my tips to
Broadway cares/equity fights aids is
doing a special fund for entertainers
who are affected by the corona virus so
that's something I wanted to get back to
if that's my community everyone who's
working in the theatre performance live
performance industry is really affected
by this so I wanted to use it as a
little opportunity to give back
[Music]
you
[Music]